- Ladies and gentlemen,
Hasan Minhaj.
(audience clapping)
- What's up?
- [Moshe] What's up, man?
How you doin'?
- What's happenin', man?
Yo Reza, Mos, you got 'em.
Close the doors!
(laughing)
- Thank you for joining us.
Are there any
memories that stir up
when I say that phrase
being Muslim in America?
- For me, it was September 12th.
I remember when it
happened my dad, basically,
sat everybody down at the table,
and he was like, all right
Hasan whatever you do
do not tell people
you're Muslim,
do not talk about politics.
And I was like, all
right cool this rubs off.
(audience laughing)
And we're sitting
there, phone rings,
Dad runs over to the phone.
We both grab the phone
at the same time,
and we hear this
voice on the line,
and it was like,
"Hey camel jockey,
where's Osama?!"
My dad's like, what?
He's like, "I'm gonna
(beeps) kill you!
"(beeps) lane, that's
where you live, right?!"
Click.
We sit down.
I hear foomp, foomp,
foomp, outside.
So, me and Dad, we run outside,
and all the windows on
the Camry are smashed.
Toyota Camry, car of
choice for immigrants.
(laughing)
All the glass is
shattered everywhere.
I look in the middle
of the street,
my dad is sweeping
glass out of the road
like he works at a
hate crime barbershop.
He's like, oh man
we got customers,
the neighbors'll see we
got a clear this out.
I'm livid.
I'm like, man these kids
they're pranking us,
they know where we live.
My dad's just barefoot,
super calm, brown Mr. Miyagi.
And I'm like, Dad what's wrong?
And he goes, "This is the
price we pay for being here.
"So, we lucked out."
And that's when I realized,
my dad's from that generation,
like a lot of immigrants
who first come to America,
where they feel like
you gotta pay this thing
like the American Dream tax.
You come here, you're
gonna endure some racism,
and if it doesn't
cost you your life,
well hey you lucked out.
Pay that tax.
There are some days where
I'm like, he's right.
Put your head down,
go be a doctor,
get a house in the
burbs, laugh later.
And then I'm like, wait
maybe it's our job,
our generation, to
push the needle forward
little by little, and make
it better for all of us.
So, I say this a lot, man,
a lot of times, a lot
of immigrant communities
are Republican in the sheets,
and Democrat in the streets.
- And then, there's a
lot of Alt-Right guys
that are Republicans
in the sheets,
and they live in the sheets,
and they wear sheets,
they're in the Ku Klux Klan
is I guess what I'm saying.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Hasan Minhaj.
(audience cheering)